hey guys scary excited to do a
garyvaynerchuk.com video for the first
time with a live audience but I wanted
to talk to you guys about something that
I've been thinking about forever
and I finally want to do a little video
about it and it's talking about sitting
on assets and eyeballs there's a company
that's doing something that I think is
extremely smart and it's not a company
that I would say has the hottest brand
equity in the space and it's not even a
company that I'm quite sure health-wise
where it's going as a business it's kind
of going out of the time-warner wing and
its own and that's a o L I'm sitting
here today in 2009 saying Big Ups to AOL
cuz I think you're doing something
extremely smart and I think that Yahoo
and Microsoft and people like the New
York Times and the whole newspaper
industry and magazines as a whole and
television as a whole should be copying
what a o L is doing and what a o L is
doing is this AOL is using it's not cool
brand aol.com and they're using it to
build a lot of cool brands AOL has been
building new platforms little blogs out
there like asylum like lemon drop like
popeater on and on and on all these
properties that a was building many of
them are becoming top in their niche
because when people go to the AOL comm
homepage they're linking to it and
they're building up these assets that
don't have the negative brand taste in
their mind and it's [ __ ] brilliant
because what's happening is they're
gonna be able to monetize that they
already have they're selling quite a bit
of ads on these other platforms these
sub sites these little satellites it's
almost a little bit of a Soviet Union
play little Czechoslovakia we're a
little hungry over here and it's quite
smart for business I really think that
Yahoo and Microsoft would their
mothership homepages should really
consider going after that as more and
more is gonna become about filtering and
niche and hyperlocal
these guys have massive eyeballs but
they're losing them every single day
thus why I talk about the newspaper
industry my opinion the New York Times
every day on the front page
should be plugging and it doesn't have
to be Tokyo and Times Square
it can be subtle and classy but if
they've got an article about pop I mean
there's daily politics that area well
just launched I don't understand want
the New York Times into Wednesday food
section doesn't have a little box and
says to see more about this go to daily
food calm or whatever is available or
food for lovers of loving food net I
don't care what I care about is they
have eyeballs still a lot of them less
than they did before and a lot less than
they're gonna have and before they just
go down on this huge ship and sink why
not create all these little boats that
all your sailors your journalists can go
to and build and build up with fresh
brand equity what AOL is doing is
extremely smart and what I think a lot
of big platforms should be doing is the
same and now we want to take it one step
further now I'm starting to think about
it even within a small niche like my own
wine library site should I be creating
sub sites like Cabernet today
maybe I should maybe I will and maybe
you have a lot of eyeballs that are
maybe kind of going in the right
direction or maybe you're not as happy
with the brand overall or maybe you're
passionate about a niche within that
global play use that big mothership to
send eyeballs to these other islands
there's huge money going that way in the
future I promise you I made this video
so that I can show it to you in three
years and say I told you so I hope
you're having fun with your family have
a great day